[Music]
hi
everybody and welcome back to another
pie data global sponsor interview
i'm james powell i serve as co-chair of
the non-focus board of directors
as well as vice president of pi data
today i'm joined by leo dreifenschmidt
from dadaiku who will be telling us a
little bit more
about how dataiku approaches
contributions to the open source
community
as well as tries to bridge the gaps
still remaining between
ml practitioners ml researchers and ml
business users
so leo would you like to introduce
yourself to the pi data global community
hi i'm leo i'm the research director
here at daraiku
i've been at dark for about five years
now and i'm in charge of developing all
of the machine learning
uh feature within the product
and leo would you like to introduce your
team at data aiku and
aiku as a whole to the pi data global
community so daraku we are a software
editing platform we are building
data science studio it's a software
which is end-to-end
from the collection of the data to the
cleaning of the data
to training the machine learning model
to deploying into production so that's
what we do
and within that we have the research
team which is the lab
which is that i could lab and our goal
is really to understand
what can we bring to our user which is
innovative in terms of national only
which has some kind of scientific
uncertainty but that we really believe
has impact and value for our users
so leo tell me a little bit about the
tools from the pi data ecosystem that
you use
and in your team at araku yeah sure so
we use many
many of those tools mainly python based
so i think we're big big user of numpy
scipy pandas uh of course scikit-learn
uh for all of the nationality models and
then other things i think like uh keras
for deploying tensorflow and pytorch
uh for visualization many things when we
stick with python it's a lot of uh
things within jupiter and upload lib um
sometimes a little bit of bokeh
uh and i think that's about it for the
main python based tool that we use in
the team fantastic tell me a little bit
more about your use of bouquet
so bouquet i think we use it mainly when
we try to like
build some kind of like easy and simple
dashboard that we want to share with
people so usually what we would do we
will do machine learning experiments
then we want to communicate those
findings those insights in a better way
than you know just giving uh
tables and numbers so we want to make
that interactive
so if we can we can leverage things like
bokeh or tools
would it be fair to say that you're a
big user of scikit-learn and that's
probably the tool that excites you the
most
we're a very big user of cyclic line so
that's that's for sure uh
we have a deep i mean we have a deep
relationship with with the second
community
and we've been using it a lot throughout
the years so it's it's something i
really enjoy we like the way the
community walks around second land there
is apis
it's very nice to work with and uh yeah
so we are a big user of cycle learn
that's for sure
in fact i understand that you're a
member of the scikit-learn consortium
can you tell us a little bit more about
why you've been motivated to contribute
back to psychic learn
to such a degree sure um so yeah so
we're first we're very proud to be part
of that constitution
we've been dressed since day one um i
think we have common
common interest as a machine learning
researcher that cyclone does we want to
make available for a broad range of
users all of the machine learning tools
and we've been using cyclone a lot
within our product within our platform
and so we thought it was
just natural to to you know somehow to
give back
to be there to to help them guide them
if we can without feedback from our
users from the industry
and also i think also in terms of
development sometimes it happens that we
are interested
in developing topics and it's the same
for them so we have to work
collaboratively
and whenever we can we're very happy to
to push this very completely
throughout sprints throughout different
feature requests
and working directly on the future
ourselves so uh it just makes sense for
us to be to be very in the community
do you encourage people on your team to
give back to psychic learn in the form
of code contributions
yeah very much so so as psychic learners
over topics we
we we encourage a lot everybody to take
out of sprints or anything
you know that's part of like the open
source community we think it's great we
think it's a good occasion to meet other
people to discuss over
techniques over issues to see over codes
to read some other stuff
and uh it's very important and we every
year we've presented that virus prints
so very much something that we want our
people that are good to be part of
contributing to an open source project
is very time consuming the standards are
very high because they have to
you know every contribution has to make
sure that it affects
the entire community in a fair way that
it's not unduly
privileging one person who's making the
contribution that it's not solving one
person's use case but failing to solve
other people's use case
and as a consequence there's a lot of
time and energy that's necessary in
order to make an open source
contribution
so where do you see open source
contributions making a real benefit in
your personal life or in the life of the
folks who work for you that's a great
question
so first yeah you definitely right it
takes a lot of time a lot of energy
but i think we all think first it's
nothing is mandatory we don't
force people to contribute you know
within the team uh we encourage them we
want to help them do so we want to
you know give them the tools and the
help so that they can be the most
efficient contributors
but then as you said it is something
which is very time consuming i think the
benefit comes as in
first people are very proud to
contribute to open source community
this you know this really just feeling
like you know i've been able to like
give back
to a framework that i use a lot so i
think this is a huge drive for everyone
so even though it's been month sometime
years actually on some
pull requests and some features uh you
know at the end i think people are very
very happy with that
so it is important as a that we kind of
like measure how much time it takes
from them you know on the daily work but
uh i think once it's come from such you
know
a good place people aren't enthusiastic
to do so so
they don't count the hours and just you
know go on and do it
so i understand that who is hiring what
positions what roles what profiles are
you hiring for
yeah we are hiring uh globally around
the globe
and for virus technical positions so
data centers
people who help our clients make their
data sense particularly reality
we're hiring for software engineering
and fire fires part of their
stack specifically in machine learning
was a hiring for
a research scientist so people needed a
research team who helped
you know find and develop innovative
machine learning driven
products and also from architecture
people who
can help us you know design uh big data
architecture
for our clients so i think the scope is
very very broad
um so if anyone is interested we'll be
super happy to have you apply uh
our jobs what kind of thing makes
a candidate stand out when they're
applying for your team
it's a great question again so you know
what i think you know
uh it's very hard right now because
there's a lot of people applying to a
lot of to different jobs so
it's you can only spend a limited amount
of time looking over somebody's resume
and i would say two things that's a lot
when people has github projects that we
can look for
when they have strong you know research
background where we can check
and i think everything here relates to
what do you know how
involved they were within the community
if whether it's the mesh learning
research community or the machine
learning
software engineering community but
having those projects
you know it kind of shows that if you
were a junior you didn't just go through
school and did
you know what you were supposed to do
but you know you went out there you were
curious
you started things on your own you start
exploring and if you're more advanced
you just didn't do what
you know job asked you to do but you had
that curiosity to try things and i think
that's also why i think being involved
if you can in an open source community
project is a great way you know to get
exposed
to to those type of things and this is
definitely a big plus
when i want to see somebody who comes
with certain expertise
i understand that dataku is a big
proponent of
open source and specifically the pi data
stack but
speaking honestly what pain points or
what growing pains do you foresee
for the tools that we're using today i
think
you know i don't know if it's a pain
point per se but
i would say that sometimes it's hard to
to stay up to date
with all the latest release with all of
the things that we have on board with
the tool that we use and also sometimes
we have to make decisions without having
the visibility of where those projects
are going
uh it happened in the past we got like
oh we need to push that feature
you know further uh so we're moving away
from the base implementation and then
maybe six months later nine months later
you know
it comes in the base uh
package that we were interested in the
first place we're like oh you know if we
had known that
i don't we would have known it that way
should have got in touch with those guys
i would say this you know staying up to
date with everything that's going on
having more visibility uh and also you
know i think having more visibility is
also a great way to see like oh if you
guys
are going that way then we'd be super
happy to contribute because we have you
know feedback from the industry we have
our own interests
so i would say that's something speaking
about keeping up to date how do you keep
up to date
as you get more senior the amount of
time that you have to go through change
locks is
definitely much less than when you're
junior that's true
so i think there's many ways to do that
first within the team we have different
people with virus expertise
so then each one is the owner of this
topic as a researcher as a machine
learning
engineer so they are following very
closely on
the scope of their field i would say so
that's a great way to have
more people following more projects and
then i would say
joining meetups joining uh various
events like sprints like conferences
is always a great way to to to keep on
top of things so
after each conference even if i can make
it i would just
binge what all of the conference talks
and be like oh this is what i need to
know now
tell me a little bit more about building
a community between machine learning
practitioners researchers and business
units is this important and how do you
go about doing that
yeah um so first i think as researchers
within a company uh so we are really
much doing apply research
we we can see that there is some kind of
like disconnect between the academic
research
the pursuing state of the art results
you know depositing that that extra
percent
and on the other hand you have the
national practitioner
uh and they need something else they
need something reliable they need
something robust they need something
that works in every situation you know
not gonna be the best
in that specific one they don't want to
overfit a little board if you want
and they also need to share what they do
defining with other users
which are not technical so that's where
we see ourselves we are trying and i
think
in darwin i think the open source
community is also helping when doing
that
to you know make that connection build
that gap
and that's really the sense of our
research we're trying to detect what we
can
and push further what we see in the
research community
but but build that in a way so that it
could benefit
a larger audience two of your colleagues
will be speaking at pi data global will
they be sharing some of the research
that they've done
with the pi data global community yeah
exactly yeah we're very happy this year
we had uh
two to talk one by alexander abraham is
going to be talking about active
learning which is a
great topic we have around labeling is
and we actually open source our own
solution which is called cardinal
so we have a talker called cardino a
matrix-based active learning framework
and then we have another research
scientist of ours which is similar
maggio
uh who studied this here uh globally
what we call machine learning debugging
and it's about learning and
understanding uh
where you model make mistakes so it's
called learning from your model's
mistake
so i encourage you to go and check it
out give us feedback
because that's how the community should
work uh and maybe you can go around and
play with i've also princess project
that we are
just started to release so tell me a
little bit
more about the local efforts that that
aiku has made
to support the local communities i
understand data who's a big supporter of
the paidita paris meetup group
what motivates you to support these
local communities in that way i think
you know
we we used to be a small startup when i
joined that i could we were i don't know
maybe 20.
now we're about 500 people uh and so i
know what it is to be
uh to have you know limited uh
i would say funds to be in a small
office and so
usually we see that those type of
efforts from the community you know they
kind of struggle sometime to find
right just you know just a room to have
people
meet and talk so that's what we did
earlier this year before the covid we
did that with
uh the paris pi data we hosted the
meetup we were super happy to do so and
you know it's another way i think
for us to give back you know it's not
only about giving back in contributing
as a researcher or as an engineer it's
also giving back as you know
we we can't afford to you know to have
people stay
with us at the office uh we also did
that with sprints
where we hosted some sprints uh that was
another great way to
to be embedded in the uh local
activities of uh
of the datasense ecosystem here in paris
but
also in new york so yeah that's what we
do is it not the case that your
contributions to the scikit-learn
consortium
and to num focus in the form of
sponsoring pi data global
take into account that the
sustainability of these projects is so
difficult
and as a consequence you need to have
some centralized organization or at
least some
community supported organization i
should say helping to mainta
ensure that these projects are sustained
over the long haul
i agree and i think specifically i would
say that it's not the same type of
people
you know you i understand that when
you're a software engineer a coder or a
nationalist researcher
you know you do you want to take the
time out of coding out of doing the
research
how to do the science to you know to do
the communication to do the publicity
to do all of that to bring the community
together to find a room to talk
you know it's another job and i think
it's it's something that not everybody
we
that directly contribute to those
projects want to do
which is fine and so i think it's
important that we have other folks
contributing in other ways
uh to make you know to make all of this
thing hap
happening and uh yeah i think this is
without that nothing you know it will
only be a bunch of coders and geekers
on their own and uh you know nobody will
talk
except on github leo is there any final
message you would like to leave the pi
data global community
yeah first come see our talk we have two
amazing talks we are looking forward to
having your feedback to have your
questions and we hope we can
talk we have a booth as well so if you
have any questions about what we do
about our research topic about our
software about anything we very much
like to hear from you
and uh last plug on cardinal
active learning solution if you want to
have a look it's on github it's open
source
and we're looking forward to any
contribution so stay tuned
thank you leo for joining us today for
our pi data global sponsor interview
i really enjoyed hearing a little bit
more about how you're trying to bring
together the research community
the practitioner community and the
business community as well as details of
how daraiku
approaches its contributions to open
source thanks a lot
thanks everyone bye for now bye
[Music]
you